and then i think one of the best books
probably ever written is uh i think it's
called
when breath becomes air um or air
becomes breath i can't remember
uh but it's basically a doctor or a
medical professional
who's dying and he essentially writes
about
the experience and thoughts and kind of
all the stuff and
i think that it's just uh one of these
things where if you said to me you know
what's the number one thing i took out
of my experience in iraq
that's a book like that also gives you
is we're all going to die
right and you and i can want to be as
immortal as we want but at some point
we're going to die
and so it really does kind of focus you
on
time being that scarce asset and use it
for
enjoyment and happiness uh more so than
anything else and i think that's part of
your message
and it's a great one do you do you think
do you like literally meditate on your
own mortality
i necessarily think i uh meditate on it
as much as um
are you afraid of death were you afraid
of death when you're in iraq i mean if
you're coming face to face with it
are you afraid of death today no i think
that it was just one of these things
where like
if you fixate on something and you worry
about it
then at least to me like you become
uneasy about it
and so after an experience like
going to war i think that everything is
just
so not important compared to that right
like when i came back i remember
going back into the college environment
and like things people were worried
about
i was like listen let me explain to you
you know what the real world's like
right but i think even today right if
you talk to people who know me really
well
i don't get worked up about a lot of
stuff i don't get you know in either
direction
good or bad uh anything because
ultimately it just comes down to
if that's the final result let's enjoy
it
you